bom eu queria primeiro que tá aqui pra
mim é talvez hoje que a maioria das
pessoas não tem noção do que significa
aqui vocês vão entender um pouco agora e
fazer toda essa construção do que eu vou
falar agora pra mim foi transformador e
eu queria começar fazendo duas perguntas
simples
a primeira é o seguinte tenta puxar na
memória de vocês em algum ponto da vida
de vocês e vocês deixarem de fazer
qualquer coisa de aprender qualquer
coisa por que você achou que ele era
totalmente inútil quando alguém chamou
para uma palestra você falou estou com
preguiça cada quilo também o tipo de
coisa que eu nem queria aprender
aí não vou passar a tarde na casa da
minha avó porque ela quer ensinar a
fazer um bolo eu não tô a fim de
aprender a fazer bolo na casa do meu tio
que é mecânico ele passa o dia inteiro
falando de como é com certa o carro pois
não interessa por isso a segunda
pergunta eu quero fazer é o simples
quantas vezes na vida de vocês vocês
consegue se recordar de que alguma coisa
que aprendeu e achou que era totalmente
inútil totalmente inútil
você os oitos assim caramba eu achei que
nunca ia ser visto na minha vida e
aquilo de repente salvou de uma situação
o que ajudou a criar alguma coisa
diferente é sobre isso que eu quero
começar a bater um papo com vocês vão
começar contando uma história na verdade
um recorte de uma história e quando se
fala de tex vai aparecer no início muito
xixi e ela é clichê eu quero falar sobre
a fala um recorde numa fala de steve
jobs em que ele fala instinto foi
inclusive essa fala está com essa roupa
inclusive que é bem famosa e lá está ele
foi até a faculdade inclusive que ele
deixou e ele faz a primeira piada sobre
isso ele foi quando ele volta ele disse
estou aqui na faculdade realmente eu
deixei ele fala que quando ele resolveu
deixar a faculdade e não querer mais ir
à faculdade
ele não deixou a faculdade de vez ele
simplesmente foi deixando aos poucos ele
disse que não queria mais estar ali mas
ele demorou quase um ano e meio para se
soltar da faculdade este ano e meio que
ele continua freqüentando ali ele não
queria sentir um inútil está fazendo
nada ele começou a escolher algumas
coisas que ele achava interessante mas
que não poderiam acrescentar nada na
vida deles
ali ele resolveu da caligrafia ele fez
um curso de caligrafia ele fala que esse
recurso quando estava fazendo embora é
fosse algo curioso e que foi muito
bacana pra ele ele tinha certeza que
aquilo era algo que seria totalmente
inútil para qualquer momento da vida
dele
em 1984 ele lançou a emec dólares 1 e
mac não um macintosh mac depois o
macintosh 84 que tinha impressionante
128k de memória nem 18 estou falando
agora caberia no computador anos ter
noção o quanto que ele não tinha peso
mas uma coisa chamou a atenção não é que
então achei 84
a tipografia todas as letras e os
espaçamentos que tinham macintosh chamar
a atenção do mundo inteiro alerta do
primeiro computador você podia comprar e
colocar em casa mas ele fala que dez
anos depois tudo aquilo que ele aprendeu
na caligrafia que ele achava que era
totalmente inútil serviu para a vida
dele para transformar aquele computador
que ele criou toda aquela tecnologia de
incríveis 128k que serviu simplesmente
para que tinga grafia fosse algo que
chamasse a atenção
estou contando a história dele pra ver
um pouco da minha história lembrando que
não tem nada a ver a minha história com
a de steve jobs mas eu lembro que quando
era adolescente eu sempre fui apaixonado
por circo sempre foi apaixonado por ser
um vizinho meu uma base comunitária aos
21 morava na periferia ele começou a
fazer aula de marabá smo ele queria
começou a fazer malabarismos chegou lá
contando vantagem e eu estou fazendo uma
na bahia e todo mundo aqui mas agora
está fazendo malabarismo eu virei pra
minha mãe que ia fazer malabarismo minha
mãe toda preocupada com a minha educação
com a minha formação de seu filho eu não
vou te proíbe de fazer se você quiser
fazer malabarismo vai lá mas eu acho que
devia focar em coisas sejam mais úteis
para você porque quando a gente nasce na
periferia a gente tem que aprender que a
gente tem que estudar então você tem que
estudar se você quiser eu te pago um
curso naquela época um curso muito
moderno de datilografia muito moderna de
datilografia nos cabelos brancos entrega
um pouco a umidade e eu falei tudo bem
mas mesmo assim eu fui aprender fazer
malabarismo eu não fui fazer o curso lá
na base comunitária porque minha mãe
queria que eu estudasse ela estava
correto tinha que estudar mas o meu
amigo vizinho
começou a fazer começou a me ensinar e
eu fui aprender fazer malabarismo e
estou falando dessas duas histórias
porque eu acho que o que está
acontecendo um pouco neste momento que a
gente vive é que a gente tá esquecendo
dos pequenos aprendizados está vivendo
num mundo onde cada vez mais a pressão
de que você tem que ser o melhor no que
você faz da melhor forma e você consegue
ser melhor mas pra isso o caminho está
cada vez mais assim ó apertado é tanta
pressão para você ter foco em tudo que
está fazendo que um estudo recente foi
lançado agora e nos últimos seis anos
subiu em 37% o caso de crianças
adolescentes e jovens adultos com
depressão e ansiedade
tudo isso baseado no mercado que diz
para ele o seguinte cara cê tá aí mas já
está atrasada e thaisa ó falar tem que
estar lá não ser tomar no mercado que te
impulsiona o tempo todo e dizer pra você
assim ó ser totalmente errado se você
não fizer só isso é que você não vai
conseguir chegar a lugar nenhum no mundo
hoje que infelizmente vem de base de
rede social que diz pra gente todo mundo
é especialista em tudo você não
então você não é nada corra e isso
começa a gerar pressão isso começa a
gerar aquela aquele momento a gente
começa a sentir como triste
aí vem a ansiedade depressão e isso
embora tenha crescido 37 por cento nos
jovens
eu tenho certeza que muitos adultos que
estão vendo isso aqui agora pensam da
mesma forma eu estudei me formei e
quando entrei no mercado eu estou
trabalhando a cinco dez anos eu continuo
achando que estou atrasado porque as
pessoas vão me pressionando cada vez
mais e hoje engraçada que o mercado que
mais se preocupa com o futuro é de que
nós vamos substituir anos todos
substituídos por robôs em grande parte
da nossa vida a gente vai ser sim
substituídos por robôs
mesmo que a gente não queira mas tem
dois pontos que os robôs ainda não estão
sendo bem feitos estudos para que eles
possam fazer e eles são sociabilidade e
adaptabilidade nenhum desses dois pontos
sua bolsa onde consegue fazer
tranquilamente lógico um dia o robô pode
estar vendo este vídeo e
minha cara dizer como ele é inocente de
bobinho que eles eram não é mesmo
mas hoje nada leva a isso estou falando
de sociabilidade eu estou falando do
meio que eu vivo isso eu estou falando
de ser adaptável de ter a adaptabilidade
eu estou falando da forma de coisas que
eu aprendo e que eu consiga injetar
naquilo que eu faço no meu dia a dia e
isso é um ponto muito importante porque
você pode ensinar o roubo fazer qualquer
coisa que qualquer um pode fazer aqui
- no momento que seja algo novo algo
inesperado e você pensar poxa eu vou
pegar algo que eu aprendi lá atrás eu
vou colocar aqui porque pode ser uma
solução e isso provavelmente o robô não
vai conseguir fazer e já está tão
preocupado tão preocupado com que o robô
pode fazer pra gente está tão focado
porque o mundo nos pressiona isso o é
a gente está preocupado que os robôs vão
tomar conta então transformando todo
mundo no meio só no meio social
principalmente profissional em robôs
está falando sobre educação útil não que
ela seja ruim eu acho que educação útil
à educação utilitária é muito importante
para nossa vida é realmente muito
importante eu tenho que aprender uma
profissão para que aquela profissão me
de renda e de uma vida digna essa
educação utilitária
mas hoje todo mundo pressiona aqui você
só tem que aprender o que é um
utilitário só aprendam o que é de praxe
da profissão se você quer ser médico só
estúdio para ser médico se você quer ser
dentista só vai dar para ser dentista ou
qualquer outra área
você só foca naquilo e às vezes esquecem
de falar com a gente que diferente dos
robôs nós podemos de tempos em tempos
desfocar para poder enxergar o todo ea
gente está precisando fazer cada vez
mais isso
cada vez que a gente foca tem que
estudar a educação utilitarista que se
formasse tem que ir à escola tem que
fazer uma faculdade ou mestrado
doutorado o que você quiser
os cursos que têm a ver com o que está
transformando a sua vida mas de vez em
quando você precisa voltar e olhar assim
o todo
o que está faltando encaixar aqui o que
é que eu posso encaixar esses pequenos
aprendizados
é o que constrói um ser estudos dizem
que para os pilares para se construir um
ser o ser humano ou quem você é
vem primeiro da composição genética e
vocês sabem que o que você aprende
também vira genético e passa para o seu
filho
então tem a ver com que você tem de
experiência e aprendizagem
depois disso o ambiente que você
inserido independente se você nasceu
onde você é criado isto interfere na
construção de quem você é hoje
depois disso veio que a personalidade
familiar haja virgin de pessoas falando
o quanto é importante os pais apoiarem
os filhos seja adolescente seja ele tem
filho que já está com quase 30 mora com
os pais
mas toda essa personalidade familiar
também constrói quem você é
dentro do mercado de trabalho ou como
ser humano a sua aprendizagem vêm disso
tudo e o mais importante pra mim das
experiências e já está começando a ficar
tudo a ver cada mais fechados há
experiências daquilo que a gente deveria
aprender não só na educação utilitária a
gente começa a transformar ou nos
transformar em algo que só repete aquilo
que nos ensinaram na academia ea gente
precisa de um pouco mais do que isso eu
queria contar pra vocês que a
aprendizagem de coisas que a gente pode
entender que hoje sejam inúteis ou
coisas que a gente acha que de repente
não sabe pra vida pode transformar
várias vidas
esse cara tá na foto aqui chama-se david
blaine talvez algumas pessoas aqui não
conheço mas ele é um mágico muito muito
famoso nos estados unidos bem famoso
david blaine quando tinha cinco anos de
idade
o tio dele que era dentista e só sabia
fazer um truque de mágica fez esse
truque para de blaine entre quatro e
cinco anos de idade david belle ficou
encantado tio dele viu que ele ficou
encantado e foi lá ensinou a única coisa
que ele sabia fazer fóruns e dentista
que era um truque de mágica e quando ele
ensinou esse truque de mágica para david
blaine desde os cinco anos de idade
começou a andar com um baralho no bolso
e fazer aquela mágica para todo mundo e
isso transformou ele nos mágicos mais
famosos do mundo ou pelo menos como é
hoje conhecido nos estados unidos uma
única coisa que talvez naquele momento o
tio dele fosse tão inútil porque eu
aprendi aquela mágica e ensinou uma
pessoa transformou toda o caminho
daquela pessoa transformou toda a vida
daquela pessoa e quando eu resolvi
aprender malabarismo com o meu vizinho e
aprende fazendo malabarismo com o
vizinho e um dia eu estava em maceió
cheguei marcel sem conhecer ninguém quem
conhece a minha história
durante um tempo uma barraca de camping
na praia e eu consegui meu primeiro
trabalho aqui numa pizzaria chamada
circus pizza
e lá nas circunstâncias eu fui
contratado porque eu sabia fazer
malabarismo e quando eu comecei a fazer
malabares nos circos pizza uma moça veio
pra mim e disse o seguinte tudo bons e
dá aula de malabarismo e disse não há só
eu queria muito em que meu filho
aprendesse eu acho isso muito legal eu
falei 'não e nesta conversa eu expliquei
pra ela que era para mim que eu tinha
formação eu tinha sim a minha formação
utilitário eu tinha minha formação em
solitário mas naquele momento
malabarismo estava fazendo a minha vida
algo que no momento do meu estudo é
inútil e ela falou assim a separ men foi
o trabalho no senac e lá está presente o
professor de berlim
se você for um professor de barman tão
bom quanto você malabarismo talvez tenha
um momento para você entrar lá eu fui
para o cenário dessa aula e passei nove
anos ensinando daquela instituição
o que me fez ficar lá foi a minha
competência sim através da minha
academia da educação e utilitária
mas o que fez aquela pessoa olhar pra
mim foi algo que eu aprendi no momento
da minha vida que eu achei que era
totalmente inútil que era fazer
malabarismo
talvez o que vocês têm o que aprender no
dia a dia que vocês possam entender que
seja inútil pode ser a única coisa que
chame a atenção de vocês e mudem toda a
trajetória de vocês
aprender coisas experiências é o que faz
da gente únicos
o que vai diferenciar um robô é uma
única coisa que eu posso fazer que ele
não pode fazer por mim escreveu o
roteiro
dificilmente irá encontrar um robô
consegue escrever um roteiro por exemplo
ainda mais escrever o roteiro da minha
vida que só eu sei o que eu passei
e mesmo que eu conte pra ele vai ser
seco vai ser colocado as emoções quem
coloca sou eu sendo ficção sendo verdade
eu construí suíço só eu posso fazer isso
porque vamos fechar aquilo tudo que eu
posso aprender o que está na minha volta
e é disso que estou falando sobre a
aprendizagem de corrente o que é a
aprendizagem não será a junção do que
você vê e sente as experiências que você
tem
o acúmulo daquilo que você conhece que
geralmente muda porque habilidades que
você tem na vida acabam ficando
obsoletos quando as profissões não
chegando eles nem sabiam existir
então imagina o quanto é importante a
gente continuar tendo aprendizagem sendo
ela que naquele momento
para essa última ou não mas aprendizagem
é isso e porque é decorrente porque
quando a gente fala de corrente é ideal
que decorre como tempo tudo que você
aprende decorrente aquilo que você passa
é absurdamente relevante por mais
naquele momento pareça algo totalmente
inútil decorrente também porque a gente
fala que tudo que a gente faz decorre de
alguma coisa então por que que eu vou
negar conhecer a o que pode de repente
com minha avó me ensinou a fazer crochê
a minha avó me ensinou a costurar mais
uma vez quando tinha uma empresa de show
bar
eu precisava de uma roupa de de mexicano
num sábado à tarde não tinha como fazer
isso conseguiu um monte de pedaços de
pano e graças à minha avó me ensinou
aquele momento inútil eu consiga
costurar e fazer a minha roupa de
tequileiros e isso me deu mais mercado
então por que eu tenho que me fechar e
aprender coisas viver no mundo hoje onde
a rede social disse que todo mundo sabe
tudo e parece que a gente cada vez menos
sabe as coisas sendo que eu tenho que
ter experiência e o mais importante de
quando você fala em aprendizagem
decorrente é que quando a gente nasce
pobre envolve uma coisa você tem que
crescer estudar e aprender e aprender a
aprender e dificilmente alguém na sua
vida disse pra você o seguinte você
também pode ensinar porque ensinar algo
para alguém não quer dizer que você tem
que ser esperto expert naquilo
o tio de bruno não era mágico mas em
cinema mas que mudou totalmente a vida
deles
o mais importante é nunca duvidou da
capacidade que qualquer pessoa tem aqui
de ensinar algo a alguém o que você tem
o que você carrega é totalmente
diferente do teu vizinho do lado
então eu tenho certeza que ele tem algo
para te ensinar que pode não ser algo
útil ao acadêmico mas o que ele tem para
te ensinar é tão importante quanto ao
que vai parar de repente aprendendo a
sua vida toda e é disso que eu falo
porque quando você de repente tem
aprendizagem decorrente vira um
aprendizado decorrente você aprende
você ensina alguém mais que ensinar algo
que você ensina alguma outra pessoa ea
gente consegue ver nos dá numa sociedade
que parece utópico mas é tão bonito a
gente tem noção de que a gente pode
aprender com todo mundo hoje está
colocando cada vez mais os gurus as
pessoas que sabem tudo lá em cima ea
gente vai se encolhendo
não tem nada pra ensinar temos cada um
de vocês carrega alguma coisa para
ensinar
eu sempre digo pra qualquer pessoa na
verdade eu estou batendo um papo é o
seguinte você pode aprender mil coisas
mas sempre que pode ensine pelo menos
uma alguém muito obrigado
[Aplausos]